All right.
Welcome, everybody.
And thanks for joining today.
It is June 9th, 2021
and we're here in Acton Flat,
North Stream, number 3.1 with Dobson,
Saffron Knight, Ratner and Friedman.
Today is going to be a fun discussion.
We hope that you're also able to,
if you're watching live,
ask us some questions because certainly
we don't have much planned
and would appreciate
from that feedback with you.
We're just going to jump right into it.
And by way of introduction and welcome,
ask what is active influence
and how we got here.
We're going to go around
and give just some initial conditions,
initial thoughts on these questions.
From wherever we're coming from as we
sort of converge on this discussion.
And then we'll just be
writing down thoughts
and ready to jump in
and continue the discussion.
So who would like to give a first pass
on either or both of these questions?
If I could try.
Thank you, Adam.
Go for it.
So for me,
active inference is a normative
process theory for how?
A principle of what it takes to exist.
The free energy principle or what
it takes to persist can be realized
and it's
what are the things you have to do
if you're going to have,
I want to say to outsource your entropy
or avoid getting all mixed up in the meat
grinder existence or whatever.
What kind of intelligence,
what kind of modeling
will you need to exhibit to do this to
And so, in a way, it's
for me, the answer to the question
of what is mind
and potentially
with certain versions of it, what is life
and what other versions
of it, what is consciousness
and maybe even what is free will.
Nice big questions.
And how did you get here?
I have no idea.
It all started with an existential crisis
when I was young.
That went on for a very long time.
But then I would say I found my way to
the architect, Karl Feresten
when I was basically through Jeff
Hawkins book on intelligence.
I learned about predictive coding,
and that was my honor
to Carl's work and the rest is history.
Awesome.
So we heard some big general ideas.
What is mind? What is life?
Who else would like to go?
Or I'll give a thought.
For. Blue one and go for it.
Sure.
I came to active inference
through my interest in scaling.
So how do you scale processes
like at like from very small,
like subatomic
to cellular to organismal to societal.
So that that was kind of how
I got hooked into the active inference
framework.
And and for me, it's a framework
that pretty
gives a pretty good representation
of how we tend to represent
and think about the world we predict.
We have feedback from like we predict
something will happen.
You know,
if I turn the thermometer on the,
if I turn the temperature up
that the heat will go on.
So we predict that we take the action.
And if the heat doesn't go
on, we have a surprise.
And so, you know, we then we go, well,
what what made our model go wrong?
Right. Like, maybe my heater is broken.
So it's kind of minimizing the surprise
and uncertainty
in our interactions in the world.
Awesome. All right.
Well, either
the two of you you'd like to go or.
Shoshanna, do you want go today?
Go ahead.
What are you.
Go ahead. OK, so I'm.
I'm perhaps in some sense outside of
because I'm not the
I'm not doing research with
active interests, but I'm a philosopher.
My background is in philosophy,
and I think active in
is a very interesting thing,
first of all.
First, of course,
I like to speak general questions
that Adam raised at the beginning.
What is mind, what is life,
what is consciousness?
And it's very close
to what I normally think about.
I'm a philosopher.
I'm a bit skeptical
whether one could actually answer this
big question in a very
succinct. But.
That's a different story.
I think Active in Friends
is very interesting from a philosophical
historical perspective
as well, because it kind of
embodies a tension
which ran through philosophy
or through the history of thinking
and which more or less started
a very famous philosopher,
a man who can't make the distinction
between
an object.
Well, he called it the world in itself,
like an outside world.
And the way
you helped me to confirm this,
and now we can go to waste from here
one more.
One could stay in the pantheon
and paradigm
where the question is
how do we actually perceive or are able
to make representations of the outside
world of who's going to the different
direction and say, Oh,
it's really about acting in this world.
And Active in Friends is a kind of
an interesting
twist mixed between these two ideas.
And my experience with it,
that some thinkers in the Active
in Friends camp,
they tend to align closer
with the new Kantian tradition
and the other line of thinkers.
They tend to
align more closely to this perception
action way of thinking.
So I'm very interested in this tension
maybe
to think about how it could be resolved.
And so I'm curious
and how did I get there?
Like well, I worked a lot with Shana
here and Shana basically and
got me, so yeah.
So Shana.
Thank you, Robert.
Shana, go for it. Yes.
So right, what with active inference.
So I too, I'm
probably more outside than Robert is.
I'm the math person here,
so I've just sort of off in the woods
trying to think about like that
how to scale all of these theories.
So you have this formalism
and activism and, you know,
inference based on sort of discriminating
between system in its environment.
And I think that's predicated upon a kind
of a very serious boundary argument.
So I'm really interested in boundaries.
I'm interested in also
how boundaries are predicated
upon also a possible holographic theorem
so when we say no agent
is interacting with this environment,
how does that actually work
in a categorical way?
So we haven't been using it
as a probability way,
but I'm sort of interested in
how do you do that categorically and
can you mathematicians that even more
and sort of infinity categorical by that
and perhaps like the definition
between inside and outside is
I think, a very, very beautiful one.
And so how can we actually say that
what is represented in
the outside is the inside
inferred?
Like what are the mathematics of that?
Also, this seems to be happening
in a certain version
of a similar simultaneous ness.
So when I understand the mathematics
and science and also this sort of
synchronic
and diachronic emergence of phenomena.
So I think that what's happening
also in the
I think the active inference
formalism is dynamical enough
to allow for these sort
of mathematical ideas to come in.
And if you can mathematicians
that then perhaps you're going to
answer these questions
that Adam was asking
what is consciousness, what is mind?
And those are those are the heavyweights.
And I think that's why
you have the heavyweights of this panel
as opposed to just like for the question,
how did you get here?
I'm trying to figure that out myself.
So I didn't know that
then it's like existentially or whatever.
Somehow I just kind of came on line.
If you want to know how I got like
in this interface, I don't know.
And then
but my
very good colleague Jill gave a talk
and I sort of attended and I see.
So he was asked a question.
I sort of answered it.
And then community like welcome me.
So that that's how I got here.
But I don't know how I got here.
Amazing. Awesome. Thank you.
And yep, excuse
any strange noises in my background.
What is active inference?
I really like just a bunch of pieces
that people brought up.
Robert, you brought up that there's
this action elements,
this pragmatic turn, looking at action
and perception in the world.
And then right there,
the second word is inference,
and that's not transcendental
or like a Kantian type approach.
So when I look at active inference,
I see action and inference
sounds a little first level,
but those are the two pieces
that are coming together,
which is traditions of action
in the world
and traditions of inference in the world.
Now, as compared with reinforcement
learning
or other approaches to thinking
about agency and action in the world
or other economic metaphors, active
inference diverges in a few key ways.
It focuses on the reduction
of uncertainty rather
than the maximization,
for example, reward or value alone.
So uncertainty reduction is a key
component of active inference
and also what Adam brought up,
which is the resistance to dissipation
and the characteristics of living systems
to be actively resisting by making
increasingly adequate generative models
of their niche resisting dissipation.
And then also I see
active inference as a bridge
to disciplines and communities
such as systems engineering
or ecological psychology or embodiment.
And so all these different areas
that relate in one way
to action and inference or to philosophy.
There's so many roads
that come together, active inference,
and that's a little bit
about how I think I got here as well.
I remember hearing about it
for the first time from Yellow
Bruno Burke,
who came on an earlier stream,
and it was a picture of,
I think, a Dutch person
holding a cup of coffee and listening
to music and biking with one hand
and asking about this question of skill
and of action in the world
and just raising this provocative notion
that current models
that we had for action
planning weren't doing their job.
They weren't able to explain
that person on a bicycle
so since then, I've
just been learning by doing
so cool
for this first question,
and I'm sure we can return back to it
and ask more questions
about active inference as we head on.
And of course, anybody who's watching
live is more than welcome
to ask us a question which all relay on.
Let's go to
some of our questions
that we've thought about before.
And this slide asks,
What is the role of space
in active inference or in other areas
that people aren't familiar with working,
and what is the role of time?
And then we have that non locality
for both space
and time
because maybe we're curious about what
non locality looks like
in space and time.
So anyone is welcome to raise their hand
or give a first thought.
Can I give a first thought
since that was?
Yeah, yeah.
So in the probabilistic setting
and the statistical mechanics,
it's the mathematics
that fuels active inference.
Right before you have me trying
to come in and categorize everything
just for the active inference
kind of experts in the crowd,
I was going to ask you
the role of space.
Like what is it?
So are you, you know, modeling
all of this on some kind of Euclidean
sort of manifolds, or are we looking
at something a little more interesting?
So where I come from, I'm sort of
if you really believe
there's only now, then
what does that actually translate to?
So we're going to take these sort
of powerful philosophies of like,
you know, if there really is no future
in the only or in future
some kind of potential
that you only actualize.
Now, can you translate that for me
into what your space looks like?
So quantum mechanics is working over
sort of non hour comedians this
where you have a very severe cutoff.
You don't have these infinitesimals
and things.
So what like what does the space
actually look like for someone like me
who really believes that this sort of
and this interface and this greatest
that every other nanosecond
it does not exist, whatever that means.
So this whole thing is
a grand interpretation.
I just wanted to know
what you all thought about
in this inference model.
If space is actually jagged and singular
or if you're assuming
that it's
some sort of interpolated continuity
nice question.
Adam, you have a thought there.
On a few the
so most of
my thinking has been in focusing on goal
oriented behavior
consciousness agency, pursuing goals.
And this is the general, the
that's what I'm going for.
And that's like all questions end up
getting filtered through that for me.
But and
so, for instance,
and I could see space and time
in different senses
showing up in different ways.
So I'm just
now theory of consciousness.
I recently proposed
I was suggesting that we can think of it
in terms of world modeling,
but for this role modeling to actually
be capable of bringing forth the world
or being experienced for it has to have
certain coherence properties.
And so I was thinking of concentric
categories as not just preconditions
for judgment space time
cause maybe some sort of unifying
minimal selfhood,
but these are also preconditions
for any kind of sense making whatsoever
and for the appearance of the world.
People could object to that.
But then the question
about what exactly do you mean by space,
time and clause and self, how much
and what kinds in which circumstances?
And so for me, space, I tend to think of
it more in terms of locality
or there's like relative degrees
of proximity among things.
And then
there is
as for time,
it would be things changing within space
in a kind of proportional sense,
like there's other senses of time.
Like you could have some sort
of like clock like processes
that are like either in parallel and
coming to agreement or like centralize
and another sense of certain bottlenecks
that force a kind of temporal ordering
or just
thinking about like things
changing the things at different rates.
There's, I think, problematic circularity
in what I said.
But in terms of the senses of space,
well,
I'll stop there,
but I could keep going later. Now.
To just a few,
I guess, basic thoughts on space.
I thought about embodied agents
and how an agent has a location
in a spatial model.
So like the Active in France paper
that we had
where different ants
were on a different location in space.
Now there's a difference
between the space
that the actual physical thing is in
and in the model, which kind of relates
to this Kantian distinction.
Perhaps but even when we have a
disembodied agent, there's a state space.
So I don't know what is the relationship
between a mathematical state space and
whatever
you were mentioning there previously?
And then over time,
it just made me think about the
distinction between Cronos and Kairos,
where Cronos being like sort of a metric
or a measured time,
like a model of time or something
that's regularized,
and then Kairos being timeliness
and action happens kind of in both.
Action takes clock time to carry out,
but also action has its own timescale
and actions have their own
sort of story arc
yeah.
Yeah, go for it.
And then anyone else who raise your hand.
So space is something that I've thought
about a lot relative
to like my previous work.
And I think about it
a lot also in terms of boundaries, right?
So where does one thing
stop and another thing start?
And, you know, like even
something so simple as like
how do I define like my fingernail?
Like where is the boundary between
like your fingernail and your cuticle?
And anybody
who's like really dug in there, like
there's some parts of your cuticle
that you're like, is this am
I supposed to cut this or what?
Like, like, so there's,
there's not a clear distinction
or, or line that can be drawn around
what is my right?
And so trying to find this
this distinct boundary
also in terms of inclusion in a group
and I listened to your last math stream
Chana and Daniel.
And I was
I was really kind of thinking about this.
And I've been thinking about cancer
a lot in terms of inclusion in a group
as you guys were talking about that.
And it's like I also think about it
as like a school shooter,
like a cancer cell goes rogue.
Like they're somehow
not included in the group
they're not
part of the collective anymore.
And then they take on their own
like self-interested agenda.
And I also think about that,
like in terms of a school shooter
or someone that commits mass violence
and you know,
like when you have this kind of it's
someone that's not included in a group.
It's someone that even it's
not included in like like a rebel group.
Like the al Qaeda or something.
They're rejected from that group also.
So when they can't find inclusion,
they become like this rogue agent.
And so so then if I think about spaces
as in where do you draw that line?
I have a hard time finding that space
and something I like to push on
and then time.
I don't really work with time too much.
Like actually per se other than like
I have to deal with like this linear time
that we're trapped in.
But I do think about expansion
and compression of time relative to age.
So like as a young person, like time
seems to be so expanded,
like 5 minutes is forever.
And as you get older in life, like a year
just flies by, right?
So, so like as time expanded
as a young person and then compressed
as you seem to age through life.
Thank you, Blue Robert, then Chuck
Yeah.
I think there's a more of a question
and something really interesting to say,
but it's a question for you.
Maybe you can give me a good answer
because here on this slide, there's
the second word which is in parentheses
which is non locality.
And I
and my guess is that Chana put it there
and my question would be
whether there is anything
that remotely resembles some notion of
at negative influence
to make that more concrete.
My impression
when I, when I read articles by people
who are active in friends or work
in that area was that they usually
work against the very classical notion
of space and time as a background.
So you mentioned the ends
that move in physical space,
and that's usually assumed
to be a classical wall.
Or if you're
I don't know if you think about the cell
and you imply implied concepts to a cell,
then you say, OK,
the molecules, it's a classical thing.
So there is no notion of non
locality there.
I guess I don't know
and my question
would
be how, whether and how an influence
would accommodate
some notion of complicated
nice question.
We can definitely wonder
and come back to that.
Seana and then Adam.
Yeah, thanks. Yeah.
So just to get to that time part
because I hadn't talked about that,
so thanks for watching the last stream.
I'm really fascinated by time and I
don't think my time really works linear.
It's really hard to say.
Like, whereas yesterday
you could do this sort of like cone
sort of formulation
and if you want to general relativity,
then you can say,
oh yeah, yesterday is in the light
cone of whatever,
you know, so but like what is it?
And where is that?
So when I ask about the role of time,
the thing that I'm sort of,
that I proposed in that
theory diamond paper that I have
about like
the applications of all this stuff
that this higher category stuff
is to think that maybe
time is more like a protein.
So in math, you have this pro object
which is glued together from a bunch
of like morph isms
and other collections of it.
So it seems that it signs this thing
that is also emergent.
I'm the advocate that it's not fixed
right I'm also an advocate that
I don't really know how you measure time
without constructing it.
So I'm not sure that we're actually
constructing a notion of now
or does it actually exist.
So an active inference and sure
constructing every,
every second of whatever,
every unit of time,
you know, how, how can you actually
measure the inference without
constructing a parallel notion of time
in the same thing?
So we're not I'm sorry, but coherence
and know if you need a coherence property
for temporality
to actually give you a singular now
or something,
what does that actually look like?
So Robert's right.
That was me
that put the noun locality in there
because we have like a rough idea of non
locality of space.
You can have a two point
perspective of space, something like,
you know, my in my state where I'm
not like an entangled pair of photons,
I can clearly say, oh, Silver
Lake is over there and I'm in my condo.
On the other side,
there's a sort of separated distance,
but going to a pair of entangled photons,
there is no separated distance.
And so you have a two point
perspective of space.
So it's in the mastering that I did
last time.
In it, we were trying to figure out,
is there actually a two point
perspective of time?
Can you actually be a macro system
and say that this is purely non-local
so real.
I really like Robert's question saying,
where is the non locality?
I'm trying to build that
into the very mathematics of the thing of
of trying to categorize this awesome
formalism.
But yeah, so just time
I think is it's very strange
and I think it's something
that we should all probably try
to try to tackle instead of signaling
that it's always there
it's just some background phenomena.
But if time is emergent
and space is emergent also,
then it sounds like active inference
is the right dynamical formalism
that could actually
kind of
help that too, because maybe the agent
is also making time
at the same time that it's making
a. World
like yeah.
We've seen active inference models
where each time step of the model,
the agent does like a rollout
through the future
that's called
sophisticated active inference.
And then also it's a great point
about the multiple reference points.
We have two eyes at different spatial
locations, and that's how we infer depth,
which isn't just a feature of the world
because it's something
that we have to infer and therefore it's
susceptible to optical illusions.
And then the question
What time do we have a monocle?
We only have one reference point on time
because then we're going
to be
just totally unable to calculate depth
or if we can calculate or experience
temporal depth,
does that entail that we're having
multiple reference points in time?
So Adam and then anyone else.
So let's
try to bring a few threads together
so some of the movements.
So what I'm really liking
about Blue and Shower, we're just saying
is a sort of relational realism
so instead of saying like, what is time,
what is space, period?
Well, what is it relative to what?
And then
what is the and when I say coherence,
coherence relative to what?
And so
and I kind of backtrack some
in the content issue of like
is it that or just interacting
and or is it that we're modeling?
And the modeling is
just kind of a pretense that's useful
for describing this like sea of forces.
And that goes beyond description.
I think we can have both
and so what I tend to do
is view interesting systems
in terms of an act of inference.
Also like neater nested markup blankets
and you have nested
kind of nested hierarchy of dynamics.
And so you can think of, for instance,
a set of coupling processes
as some sort of chaining together
of disparate of systems
that manages to stitch
itself, hold itself together
through the way it's chained.
And this could couple with the world
in a way that doesn't require necessarily
there might be like an implicit
representation to it
if you want to use the word in that way
of like a correspondence
between the dynamics and like
what is evolving of
or you could
or that's like but it's not necessarily
it may not be inference in the sense
of like the model,
like whether you want to say
that this modeling process is real
or a way of doing things,
that's it's a matter of perspective.
But then as you add layers of complexity,
then you can get things like
inter loop
processes that could refer to this
set of kind of action relations
and bringing things together.
And then you could even
maybe have on top of those or
within those another process
which points to those.
So graphs pointing at graphs
when it graphs and so like channels
like category theoretic perspective
would be very relevant here.
But and so at some levels
you might talk of things
like representations
in a Cartesian sense, like in good old
fashioned of sites, we may have those
and we have an activist
intelligent coupling
where it's just implicit representation
and maybe we shouldn't even use that word
or maybe we should use that word.
I'm not going to say,
but we can have it all.
And so the
way that the thing like space and time,
some of these national systems,
I think there could be in a way a kind of
non locality and that they would be
evolving independently.
They're evolving on their own timescale.
So like a nested deep
hierarchy of dynamics,
there's a sense which they're all kind of
brought together by virtue of
like sharing this mark
all blanket that they ultimately agree.
So I guess I don't know if that would be,
but there's, there's potentially ways
in which they can diverge also.
And so it seems like you could have maybe
periods of not locality and locality
and actually
this kind of going in and out
and probably butchering
and abusing the terminology, I apologize,
but there's going in
and it might even be necessary
like necessary for a kind of dual phase
evolution for the systems
to couple for them
to like trade off their free energy
for them to do what they do
as a sort of like iterative
inferring their own existence
and doing what they need to do process.
But so within this
view, it seems
like time can show up in multiple ways.
It's like the
the the time of just
the world as this evolving graph
as a generative process in that way,
in terms of if there's a kind of within
if we if we narrow it in
to particular system where there is like
some things were before
and some things we're after in terms
of this sea of causal influences.
But then you might get another kind of
time of this psychological time of
spatial easing time of
and then navigating through specialized
time and same things for space.
And then it comes in again
one more thing
I guess I would say
is the issue of space and time.
I think it's going to be
two things about that. So
one idea and playing with
is actually that our consciousness
is actually the spatial kind of it
in terms of visual spatial.
This it's actually always 2D
and that to the extent that we have
something like a 3D awareness of space,
it's coherent state
transitions of these 2D projections
and there might be a relevance
to holography there.
That's one thing to say.
But one more thing would be
and then you have maybe like a 3D type
space in terms of body space.
So you have like a visual
spatial Cartesian space
and then like space relative to the body,
maybe like a kind of quasi
polar coordinate space and in between
the two of them,
you can get a kind of like 3D spacing
coming out of that surf or 40 space
because there's dynamics for it.
But the one more thing about
subsuming space and time
to action relative to
what is I think this will be crucial
for boundaries in terms of what counts
as a living system or not.
And what would count
as a conscious system
or not of what counts,
what are the physical and computational
substrates of consciousness?
What kind of closure is achieved
on what scales
that issue?
I think
so what I would like to have happen
is either some sort of
definitive handling of this,
some sort of like category
theoretic definitive handling
that would basically nail it hard.
Problem solved.
Schrödinger's
question answered, unambiguous or
I want to prove that this is impossible
and then I can rest how
thanks.
Adam.
Maybe Robert was alluding to this
with the skepticism, but for me,
whether something is answered
or not, it's a psychological story.
That we're telling.
And you can be convinced about something
that whether it's proven
to be impossible or proven to be ruled
in, that would be a story.
And then also nice
about the projective geometry.
We talked about the projective
geometry paper
some time ago about how we can look
at something like the corner of a room.
And even though the angles are going in
weird directions,
we kind of infer it to be rectilinear.
So that's pretty cool. Any
thoughts here?
Quickly on the projection geometry?
Actually,
I really love David Ross work on that
because it's like putting it's
a discussion of consciousness.
It like puts a person
or puts an observer in subjectivity
and interests
like right at the center of it
one thing I'm wondering about is
what is like
the realization of this sort of
projective geometric perspective engine
that he's thinking
we have for spatial awareness?
It seems like
there could be like a sense that just
that this is something the brain can do.
Like there's some proposals
for something like this,
like engine has capsule networks
no matter how like their thousand brains
that like there is a kind of
reference for independent modeling
happening
happening in a distributed way
as part of the architecture.
They're just like somehow through it
it works as this graphics engine
I actually think it might be a more
and inactive type thing in this
where actually the reason
you get this projective
geometric perspective capacity
is because of this coupling between body
space and visual space.
Linked by different kinds
of performance relations.
And that this is actually part of what's
letting you do these state transitions
and do this kind of projective
geometric modeling rather than
it being baked in and the distributed way
like some sort of graphics engine.
But this is another way in which like,
for instance, embodiment and interest
and value kind of other things
get subsumed to that. Like
thanks and anyone can raise their hand.
Just want on
that is action requires time.
Action is almost defined as a sequence.
And then we have the policy variables,
the PI, that's our kind of active fly pie
because policy is at the level
above a certain action of state.
But action and policies
they do take time.
So there's something
a time like built into our models
because what we're talking about
and the inferring the state transitions,
just like you described,
all those are temporal
and then the non locality,
it's kind of like when and drawing
on first and older work
with dynamic causal modeling
and statistical parametric mapping,
you have an image of the brain
that's changing through time
and then you can make one type
of connected graph
with pieces of the brain
that are anatomically connected.
And so when people think about space,
usually that's what they're thinking
about things that are touching.
But then also you could have effective
or functional connectivity
so you can have regions
that are local in cores,
but that local link in
the causal network could be
due to some
upstream factor that's influencing them
both.
So causal proximity
or functional proximity
may or may not be the same as something's
that's touching.
So you're.
Not sure where there where that puts us,
but cool stuff.
Is it.
Daniel,
can you say a little bit more about like
with regards
to what you just laid out with
action requires requiring time
and the minimization of surprise.
So is there something
and you're an active inference formalism.
When we say minimization of surprise,
is there an agent
that is creating scenarios like dinosaur,
there's no dinosaur
and somebody that can be a dinosaur?
I don't not want dinosaurs,
so I'm going to act in such a way
as to preclude
the very possibility of dinosaur.
Right? So we say minimization.
Where where is that coming from?
So is that again, or is that
is there a profound creativity
that is the basis of the system
that is launching these probabilities?
Right.
Because Bayesian probabilities doesn't
it seems kind of dull, right?
It never says that there's
this highly creative being
that is imagining these scenarios
that he wants to preclude.
So can you all tell me, like,
where's that coming form or has the agent
seen a dinosaur in in L.A.
Walking down the street and they go,
I don't want to see that again, therefore
preclude therefore action like the action
of minimizing surprise requires time.
But it's a it's an imaginary time.
It's sort of like
I don't want that to happen again.
Therefore, I'm
going to act in such a way as to preclude
the very existence of dinosaur.
Does any of that makes sense?
Well, as for dinosaurs, we know that
they're in the land before time.
So that is, you know,
it's been a while now.
It's something scary minimizing surprise,
you know. Yes.
As for the minimizing the expected
free energy or minimizing the surprises,
one of the sort of tricks of active
inference is to condition
that upon a policy,
if you look at the topology
of the graphical model,
policies are getting
plugged into the state, transitions
between here in the states.
And then what's being minimized
is the surprise
of the sensory outcomes
that are emitted by the hidden states.
So at the first pass,
without getting into this like
meta Bayesian creative energy
the agent has a set of policies
that it can carry out.
Those are the affordances
and then conditioning
on each of these policy options.
If they're discrete, like I could turn
left or turn right and then I'm going
to do a conditional expectation
on turning left.
That's my policy
or conditional expectation on turning
right on my policy.
Which one of those is going to be
my prediction of how that policy changes
the state transition matrix?
What is going to result
in less surprising sensory outcomes?
That is for a sort of fixed
set of policy options
that can be conditioned on
but it's a great question about
how do we go
from the known into the unknown?
How does the agent learn a new affordance
or maybe even generate
a new affordance internally?
So there's probably
a lot to be said on that.
But one way that active inference
speaks to it
is that when we focus on action
hand-in-hand with inference,
we can think like,
how could the agent ever navigate
a new kind of physical obstacle
like there's some kind of a wall
that you've never climbed before,
but what has to be inferred
isn't like what's on the other
side of the wall or to the nth degree,
the details of the wall.
It's enough
to have a model of bodily action
and a preference for being higher up
and potentially the affordances
that the agent does control.
It does know about those things,
like the movement of the joints
that will help it deal with the unknown,
because it's not just approaching
uncertainty
as something that has to be eradicated
by determining exactly
what's out there in the world.
Uncertainty
is something that's actively negotiated
with through usage of the affordances
that the agent already has
right.
And when you
say that or the affordances constructed
or the conditions of the system,
are they properties of the system?
Like what is the space of affordances
and is there
like a topology
on the on the affordances?
Because I'm still like if we categories
like any of this, there's a,
you know, if you work in space,
is there anything like this like,
you know,
or in that in the reflective subcategory,
which I was talking about,
these objects have reflections.
And I'm still not thoroughly convinced
that there is no duality
between a system and its environment.
Right.
So if they're working together,
perhaps these are like, you know,
duly in a sort of mathematical sense.
So if if that's the case,
then I just want to know, or affordances
like a property of the system
constructed or conditions
how like do they change radically?
Is it dynamic?
All nice questions.
The instrumentalist take so active
inference is a statistical model
that we made
and it doesn't make metaphysical claims
about what systems really can do.
It's a modeling approach.
In that case, affordances or whatever
the investigator puts into the model
as affordances. Right.
Then the question about what
the system's affordances truly are
that's a great question.
It comes back to how do systems
apparently negotiate
completely new affordances
where was flying a plane?
Where does that come into play?
Well, is that part of our extended niche,
part of our constructed nation?
So we can think about that in terms of
just the same eyesight that we had before
and the same finger movements
that we had access to before.
But now it's being deployed
in a different niche.
So the extended cognitive outcome
is just radically different.
So in the case of tooling and language
as a tool and and usage of instruments
potentially one could argue
that it's still the bodily affordances
that are being used, but higher
order contingencies are being learned
by the system
to be able to play piano or fly a plane.
So the affordance of turning the plane
left can be still seen as moving
your hand to the left on a joystick
conditioned on an agent who understands
that their preference is to move that way
and now has this sort of mapping
between what they do with their hand
on the joystick and where the plane goes
but what kinds of new bodily affordances
can we have?
That's right.
And they think they're making different
forms.
That's what's cool.
Blue.
Then anyone else with a raised head.
So I was thinking about this affordances
in relation to time
and also like in relation
to the last mass stream.
When you guys were talking about how like
when does memory start to form?
Right.
And so as you're looking
at your reflections in the diamond,
like there's
you're looking at your reflections
and then there comes a space
maybe where you can reach your reflection
and remember
if that was exactly how it was worded,
but that's like when maybe memory serves
to crystallize something like that.
Maybe, maybe I want to step in
and correct me now, OK?
That's right.
So then you know a thing about like
when you have young kids
and they perceive time, right?
I talked about expansion and compression
about time a little bit earlier.
So when a kid perceives time,
a small child,
everything is like yesterday or tomorrow
right?
Like there's
no like concept of next week,
but then we know what a week is.
So like you have these new affordances
that come with learning, right?
Otherwise, it's just before or next,
right?
It's interesting.
And so when do these affordances like
does that correspond to maybe the ability
to, to reach your own reflection
in the diamond's wheel?
And I flipped it
here to what our thoughts.
So maybe if anyone has a thought on that,
what our thoughts are. Yep.
Adam and then anyone else.
But actually before I go on, if Shannon
wants to speak to a glue just so that
actually I would like to hear that yeah.
Go for it.
But then I have thoughts.
Yep, yep. Yeah, yeah.
OK, feel free.
Well, I think it's sort of integrated
yet, you know, the diamonds are
very difficult objects, right?
That I was thinking
that could be the perfect model
and could perfect a more perfect model
of what's going on.
With memory, right?
So you have these cases that I always
talk about, you know, beautiful people,
like wearing a three second memory
from a retrograde amnesia.
So you have to ask
some of my client, like,
is he experiencing a complete
temporal, non-local allergy
every 2 seconds?
The child.
Right, child mine,
which I have a lot of, right?
Like for a child, what are the conditions
for object persistence right.
In their own very state, you know, like
with the diamond or things like that.
I think you can
model what it means to have
Shannon when I'm six and Shannon
when I'm 85 or something.
Why is it the same?
Shannon
and I don't think it is like at all.
So when you say something like,
like memory
and what are you actually looking at? So
I again, if I think there is this
duality between like this system
and its environment,
how can you actually visualize that in
this in this sort of diamond mentality?
And so the thing about the diamond,
right, is that if perhaps memory
is some kind of impurity
and you'll never actually get to it.
So if it if memory is like
a mineralogical impurity,
then you never actually get the impurity.
You just get the reflections
of the whole thing.
And so to sort of take what Blue said
and just tighten it just a little bit,
that might be more of
what's actually going on.
But perhaps the mineralogical impurity
is that if maybe if you only have it now
and then, if you're not able to access
all the other reflections
that are on the diamond,
you may not have a future
and you may not have an extended time
but there's also something to say
that has that diminished,
like your vibrant experience?
Somebody like me who's like,
you can really drop in,
can drop in very dilution,
like I am a degree of heat,
I am a degree of white,
I am a unit of sand.
His formalism is super powerful
because it's giving
becoming an action to these
individualities, these societies, right,
that somebody else would say
have that kind
of unit of consciousness or something.
So I think what I'm trying to do, combine
this notion of becoming that
individual, super individualistic, like,
you know,
I am a spoon of coconut,
like a spoonful of coconut.
That's it
with this notion of this diamond being.
And they're not just reflections, right?
They're like pro finite reflections.
So they are totally disconnected.
So that's sort of a mess that I'm sort of
I think
is like underlying
the beginnings of memory.
Maybe it's just this kind of pure mess.
And as you age or whatever age is sort of
involved in these proton coverings.
And so in the covering space,
you know, if you're working
through proprioception and things
like that, there's a lot of work
in neurology saying that your brain
probably processes more technologically.
If you're a child and you only have like
a now and a bunch of points,
you don't really have a lot of cover
in spaces, right?
Yeah.
So I think working with diamonds,
which we'll get to in a little bit.
So I think there's something
definitely at play with.
You're staring at your memories, right?
You're walking around in your past
like all the time.
So I don't ever think
you can actually get to the true memory.
And if unless you reach
like the infant state again.
Thanks, Adam.
Then Robert.
How so?
That to revisit the Affordance issue.
So if I'm
understanding things,
there could be in a way
you could say, like in any given moment,
there's like a view from the outside,
like what were the
what was the scope, the possibility
of the actual interactions for the system
given its configuration.
But because of much construction,
that's also a moving target.
So then there could be another set
of like perception of these affordances
by the system where that perception
itself changes the affordances structure.
And this can be of different varieties
so like the system in a kind of
dynamically self configuration
and the like
jostling around
and it was doing like implicit inference,
just figuring out, sussing out
what the important structure is
and then this kind of implicit perception
that there could be another level
of like explicit affordance
the perception
and each of these influencing
the other and maybe operating differently
and at cross-purposes.
With respect to
that.
I mean that paraphrasing what
try and paraphrase that
and I able to assign
this seems like a connected
this a lot of things will connect to this
from memory
and I've been thinking of
getting back to consciousness
and different forms of it.
Like what do we mean
when we're accessing something like
and what does it take
to remember things in different ways
and how does our different kinds
of awareness of what happened
relate to our ability
to remember these things?
And so you can have a kind of memory
it's just a sort of like baked in.
What would they
this a hysteresis, a kind of like, yeah,
you're pushing the thing.
And then through its
dynamics or through its it's
its material
properties, it's kind of holds the shape
and you got a memory
there of the indentation like a desire.
But in terms of this,
like holding on to memory like a,
like a Clive Waring type memory and
time does seem key for contextualization
now like Blue is saying
about the way time changes with age,
it seems like that kind of time
and the way we construct it,
one of the things he would say
like we specialize it
and we specialize it relative
to like probably relative to,
you know, us as an agents
pursuing goals in the world with this,
the inference
of different important structures
but OK well what are the different ways
though that you can relate
to this spatial assignment,
to this maybe objectified you
and then different ways of doing this?
What are the different kinds
of self-reference involved
that's an issue maybe into to later.
But one of the things
I'm wondering in terms of memory
and this might relate to like
impurities in the crystals
is that the ability
of things to get entangled
to point to themselves in different ways.
So like within this like three second
window,
there's maybe a sequence
of frames of sense making,
but there's a broader frame of sense
making of a causal unfolding.
There has a certain stability over
which it can hold itself together.
But part of what would let this
specious present this inherent
depth to to the now
might be this kind of self-reference
this where,
you know, earlier frames of experience
have predictive information
about what follows,
but then what follows as information
and points to what was in the past
the kind of you know, perspective
in predicting the future
and posting the fast pass
as part of this process
of unfolding sense making.
And it seems like
the degree to which you could do this
and the ways in which you do this,
that would be the degree to which things
might likely be likely to stick around.
I thing would be might likely
to be made salient to the fine hooks
in this process where everything's
competing with everything to keep going.
That's the ability of something
to get entangled with itself in different
ways, would provide different degrees
of sticking power
and that this would involve
things like just, you know,
multi modality like, like,
like a heterogeneous code, like maybe my,
my direct, you know, first person shooter
or point of view
is pointing to like linguistic
or linguistic code or some sort of iconic
symbolization or some sort of other
like intercept of intuitive code.
But like these
all cross cross-referencing each other
like one way
of like hooking things together.
But you can also hook things together
in terms of like an explicit
causal sequence
where it's just this to this to this
that the ball check, the shoe, the boot,
kick the ball, the ball and down the ramp
the mouse got the cheese
like the whole Rube Goldberg thing
that that could be part of a two button,
but actually more
so if it's coherence and maybe a gigantic
if it's related to basically,
then we're going to have to get
personhood into this in the nature of it
relative to
the causal streams that you have
the most familiarity with and that
fit into most of this, meaning
making hierarchy that has a visceral,
visceral grounding, a symbolic grounding.
The more of these you can come together
probably the better it'll it'll persist
and the more that impurity will
give the sparkle.
So thanks, Adam.
Robert, then we'll probably move
to the next slide.
Yeah,
this slide was the thought that was.
I wanted to say something
about the parts. Yeah.
If you still have something else,
then you don't. OK,
so first, of course, I would be curious
how active in sense people would come to
you and what they would say,
what the thought is or what it means
and just philosophically, I think that's
a very interesting question.
And there are certain kind of
traditional ways
how we think about thinking
and it seems to me that active inference
is challenging some of those
very traditional assumptions,
but I'm not quite sure how exactly.
So the first assumption
that's the obvious way
that it's kind of obvious
how active inference challenges that.
But the first assumption is
and the thinking is something which
is like a counterpart
to what's happening
physically in the physical world.
And there's thinking
which is I'm kind of opposed to it
and I think an active inference
that's that day to day
shock to me is kind of erased.
That's kind of obvious on this
second question, is
there was a long
and there's a long tradition
in thinking about thinking
which has to do or which
which says that thinking is something
which is rule based or law
like loss of thought or in a more modern
in the more modern thing, one would say,
oh, it's about information processing
or probabilistic reasoning or whatever.
And but that seems to me to kind of clash
or at least would defend them
in a logical way, always this
phenomenology of thinking in some sense.
So thinking seems to be something
direct and mediated.
And you talked about it now,
which is this particular example of that.
And I wasn't quite sure
how that hangs together
with the whole active inference
theory,
basically with the mathematics of it.
I mean,
I would naively assume
you talk about inferences processes,
which are happening
defined over some bounded system.
And so that seems to lend itself
more to this
information processing view of thinking
but that seems to be somehow
opposed to the phenomenology of thinking.
And I was wondering how you kind of
bring these things together
great questions.
One thought might be that the way
that we've seen
things like anxiety
or affective states be addressed in
inference is with a parameter
reflecting that.
And so it's almost like there's
the core active inference model,
the one that, you know, data comes into
and then there's this interpretive layer.
And so I might say at this point
that the active inference
framework doesn't make strong claims
as to the, you know,
what is a packet called thought
or what is the nature of thoughts?
Because as a skill free framework,
first off, there's the whole instrumental
ism realism.
So it could be a totally defensible
stance.
Active
inference says nothing about thought,
or maybe somebody wants to unpack it
in a way where they think it does
but at the first pass,
the things that we've seen models
of active inference
about that people experience as thought,
like anxiety or excitement
or something like that.
Those are parameters
that are named in a mathematical model,
and they don't seem to make strong claims
on the nature of thought.
Adam, what do you think about that?
And so in terms of like I guess
the good folk
and how they relate to thought and
this notion of it being in a way
separable from action and distinguished
from this in the world are just doing
and just acting up
that seems like like a good place
to to work with.
And so if we're talking about that,
it seems like it would relate
to different species
of sophisticated inference
where you would be doing these kinds
of counterfactual rollouts of what
it would be to pursue different policies
or patterns of action selection.
And for me, it would be
to the extent that it's conscious,
it would have to be
grounded out
as some sort of embodied simulation.
I want to build everything out of action
perception cycles and everything
out of sensory
motor things that I can. Ultimately,
that's going to be the grounding,
that will be the experience
that suffers.
Say the thought would only be determined
by what you simulated in your rollout,
for instance.
Like you could have a lot of I'm
just the spreading
semantic association
of just like a kind of priming effect.
And then words come to mind that
that's part of it.
And that's not necessarily like something
you're controlling in terms of pursuing
a policy that's just happening
or some sort of association
with interception
with just like a kind of resonance
your body that might play into it
parameterize this process.
But the thinking, it seems like
it would be
a mode of sophisticated inference
of generating this
counterfactual possibilities
and using them for things like
different kinds of causal reasoning,
different ways of
situating what you think
is happening or could happen sometimes.
And that's
how I would relate to thought to think.
And I don't know if the like, what
do we want from thought, we want more.
And so that might help. A great question.
And do we want to experience
the phenomenology of human thought,
which is an uncultured phenomena,
or are we trying to talk about trees
and all kinds of other things?
So everyone awesome.
Thanks for the raised hand
flu shot to Robert.
I think Shannon was first.
So the factory. Yep.
Go for it.
Oh, okay. Awesome.
Yeah, just a couple of things.
You know, just Daniel was saying
when we say thought, right?
So I'm, I'm, you know, you know,
so I don't think Spot
is like recognition of a truth
and a proposition I'm of the mindset that
I think Kierkegaard said like
all thought as a self repeating
false Socrates which yeah.
It's like, so I'm not of the sense
that thought as logic
or anything like that
because there's first
orderlogic second order logic
and it's just, you know, you think.
Like. What is pro finite thought?
So I really think we need to actually
when we say
what our thoughts we need to say, like,
what do we mean by thought?
Right.
So Robert and I have this model
of like in awareness.
So it could be that
the level of your awareness
you know, dictates
the levels of time you have
and then also what these thoughts are.
So, you know, some things like,
Oh, Rock has not thought that perhaps
the units of thought of the Rock
are just lower
than our units of perception,
something like that.
So I think it's very strong to say
that things do not have thought right
so to aspect what I thought
is it's interesting also to say
what is not a thought, you know,
so, you know,
I have these kind of interesting ideas,
like if you can model the brain as this
I would tell she's an imperfect
I would say,
is that just what this diamond does?
Then if you can actually model neurons,
as you know, these points in the
diamonds, these mathematical impurities
that are actually more prisms of schemes.
And you would say that, OK,
sort of it's more chasms,
but we know
thoughts are a little more messy
than just satisfying strict associativity
and up to conditions.
So the math can only give you
a model of the thing because perhaps
it's not strictly associative.
So I mean, we all know that you do have
a sodium potassium channel
kind of neurotransmitter
cluster network happening.
You always want it to be springtime
in your head.
You would not want like a winter
in your head where all the synapses
and the trees die and things
but nobody can tell you how the trees
in your head sort of photosynthesize.
So I know I try.
I gave that first thought.
Someone asked, well,
what are actually thoughts?
So again, if these neurons are these
geometric points and I still think
the brain is some sort
of non-local hologram sort of thing,
that its ability to rewire is profound
and also don't want to get injured.
Right.
Because there is a detrimental effect
but so
like how do you sustain this sort of,
you know,
temporal non locality
inside this for a finite condition?
Maybe Robert and I are under this
with this sort of in levels of awareness.
If you're able to achieve
sort of simultaneous,
simultaneous states of awareness,
then perhaps you could
probably get out of the idea of thought
as the truth of the proposition.
And then maybe you can
probably figure out what that is.
Again, I'm not convinced
that we're doing anything new
like what a new thought is.
I'm not really sure what that is
or if you can actually, like you
say, scale free, right?
So scale
free would be able to for us to make this
an awareness sort of phenomenon.
And so I agree with Robert.
I'm not sure if there is a contention
there between the phenomenology
of what is thought
and then the sort of perception of what
thought is again, really tricky to say.
Well, but real problems
getting new connections,
you know, and then it's like, OK,
what new connections?
And my same interface,
like not really sure how that is
so I'm glad active inference
allows for like new,
but I'm not sure
if it's like radically new.
I'm not sure if any of us would be able
to recognize something radically new,
you know? OK, I'll stop it. Nice.
Thank you.
More different blue
and then Robert for that matter.
So just so I was going to piggyback
off of your point and get into that.
So and then I have a question.
So really my background is neuroscience.
And so when you look at like the brain,
the fundamental unit of a thought
like has to come from the action
potential.
Right, Nassim
and whatever that it's happening.
But like not one action
potential makes a thought.
So so like you were talking about
how do you measure emergence?
And, you know,
there's like the criticality criticality
hypothesis, right?
So like a certain number
of of action potentials
could lead to a thought perhaps.
But but how do you quantify emergence
without a counter objects?
Right.
And so you said you kept saying this.
And so I'm going to maybe
ask you to clarify
or push on this a little bit
because a counter object,
like when I think of a counter,
I think about a counter
in terms of computer programing for
AI from zero to 50.
Count, count, count, count,
so is it like counting
the number of action potentials
or the number of ants leaving pheromones
traces or the number of pheromones drop?
Right.
So so when you think about a counter
object, is that what you mean?
By a counter object, or is there
some fundamental thing that I'm missing?
I don't think I ever said
the word counter object.
So can you tell me where I said
that? Yeah.
So it was when you were quantifying
emergence and I took some notes.
So you have built in
emergence is built into the system
versus having a counter so maybe not
counter objects that you said.
Oh yeah. It wasn't.
Yeah, it wasn't not an index. Right.
So I'm not, I'm not of the
why does I have to start at one you know,
so I don't think real numbers exist
so that that's it's
a bunch of equivalence classes.
So just putting like
50 of these things happened, I don't
really know what that means right.
But I agree with you that how do you
actually quantify emergence because.
Right, if you have too much hyper
synchronous activity, you have a seizure
and a seizure is not a thought.
Right.
Everyone so it seems to me that there is
and that's what Chris Fields
and I and everyone are after is like,
what is the stop mechanism?
The stop mechanism that you can have?
You need a clustering happening
in the neurons, right?
To actually have that thought
doesn't seem to come out of your elbow.
But if the
if the nervous system is non-local,
like I believe it is which is why
I'm an advocate for the active inference
of the embodied cognition.
If the neural system is non-local
and nobody's proved that it's not,
and then how do you actually say
when the amount of clustering gives you
something like,
look at all of us,
our synopses are bright
and perfect leaves and everything
is like beautiful in here, right?
And effortlessly.
How does it come?
How does that come?
So effortless, right? Sometimes.
And then but if you have too much firing
then you don't get it.
And it's not like the
you know, there's an actual rest
in the action potential like blue.
What's the order of neuron firing?
What are you
smaller than nanometers at that point
between firing has to be right.
It's not Planck scale.
It's not like ten to the -42,
but it's small, right?
And so with that kind of time, happening,
I'm just I'm perplexed.
You have so many layers of time
happening, neuronal firing time
like the stem cell firing time, you know.
So when I said counter,
I don't think I wasn't referring to
an actual.
Yeah.
When I yeah, I think I was saying counter
is when most people just take time
to do some kind of Geiger counter
and there's no emergence like at all.
You know, I hope I answer that
didn't make it worse.
Yeah.
So I couldn't
I couldn't figure out if you'd like
to talk about like a counterfactual,
like the opposite of emergence,
like what's the opposite of emergent.
So if you're talking about a counter,
like, you know, when you something's up.
So that's it would be a assumption.
Yeah.
Great.
Robert and Adam,
you want to go to the next one
or do you want to continue on
the thought up to you?
Well, I just had a very quick
clarification of my question.
Actually,
Adam can reply immediately after.
That's good
because Adam said something like,
What do we want
the theory of thought to be?
Or What do you want it for?
Which kind of thought are we?
Are we talking?
Or When I was asking my question
about the nature of thought, I was
mainly thinking
about conscious thoughts
I mean, there's this tradition that is
which says something like
All the mind is whatever the brain does.
And then you talk about,
I don't know, potential clues
about firing, about calcium
and I don't know what.
And if you then say, OK, well,
that's a very abstract thing
and you called it fault,
I think that's fine.
That's fine.
And one is that it doesn't really
give you a good answer
to what you mean with conscious thought
and the standard way,
how psychologists normally answer
that question is to say, OK, well, there
is this unconscious processing happening
and then something magically happens
and that turns into conscious thought.
And I wasn't quite clear
whether predictive processing
or active inference or whatever frame
you want to take really answers
that question or whether what it says,
oh, it's actually not a good question
kind of dissolves this question.
And well, that's a bit more specific
about my question.
Adam, go for it.
Try to tie a few things together.
So, yeah, so what we want from thought
and what our sensibilities might be
that is what boundaries we established
for where we find and don't.
It'll be relative to what,
what do we want
but to try to build up
so I think there is a sense
in which you could say like,
so like a rock
is a mind or is thought,
even though it's an extremely dumb
variety, it's action
because we can point to it,
it's a kind of density
and that it's you can think of it as
a, you know, it's just going to probably
unlike like Crystal, which can grow.
It was just
sort of like it can do one thing
which is steadily degrade over time.
And some kind of an trophic gradient.
But to the extent it doesn't,
that's, that's all that's
the intelligence it's got.
But then we get to systems that can like
actually through sophisticated dynamics,
start to do things like
suss out different things that can happen
and do a kind of
more flexible policy selection
and they might be potentially in it.
In order to do this, they might have to
be critically organized.
And that that's the only thing
that could allow for
generalized evolution
or generalized Bayesian model selection
that you actually have to be points
at this like inter regime
in order to have the right properties,
in order to have both the the variation
where you can suss out the possibilities,
but also the the stability
point over into chaos or disorder
that you can actually build structure
upon structure.
So it seems like
that's going to be critical
in terms of
like if you're talking about something
like ants,
like we're coming out of the like,
you know, a life form,
maybe that's like some people say like
that's kind of like,
like this sort of more sophisticated
mentality that with,
you know,
optionality,
maybe that's like the hallmark of life,
maybe this sort of hierarchical
nested modeling.
If some of these intergroup processes
are capable of bifurcating
in different ways and giving you
a kind of like intelligent optionality,
maybe, you know, that's a kind
of thought, but let's keep working up.
So if we're talking about something
like the brain
I would think of like a
a hierarchy of
nested
coupling processes
evolving on different time scales.
And in the community,
they'll tend to call these things
a non equilibrium static densities.
I call them self-organizing
harmonic modes.
And it's a way I interpret
neural synchrony.
And to the degree that you get it, it's
facilitating communication
through coherence,
making sure that within these systems,
not just like tuning in excitation
inhibition, balance to
then it works, but that to actually
within this maelstrom
to get coherent dynamics,
coherent inference,
you would
you need the neurons need to team up.
So you need synchrony.
You need synchrony for I guess what
they would call marginal message passing.
So it'd be like marginalization,
like a joint belief.
And then you packet your beliefs.
And these like coalitions are doing
like, like these units, this quantization
of sense making of prediction
error and prediction.
And so there would be like this
nested hierarchy.
And so if we're talking about
something like
let's say like gamma frequency,
that might be like a very small local
unit of like Synchrony in a sense
making a maybe that's like a
a quantization of like prediction error
that will be passed upwards.
So that's like an observation
within the scope of this gamma packet
though maybe that's like a prediction
for like whatever's inside it,
but you keep going up.
So then maybe you have
something like Beta and then Gamma like
40 times a second and then theta would be
something like, you know,
maybe high and low is a terms
like somewhere
between 13 the three times a second
and maybe you're starting to get like
a depends
where you're
at, but these higher order attractors
and these higher order predictions
like, like a like
a composition, like something like a hand
reaching, something like that,
but like where's consciousness
going to come into this and why
it seems if you can take these
different recognition,
these, this,
these recognition of different patterns
and you can stitch them together
such that you have
within the organizing principle of
I would suggest an egocentric perspective
of a particular point of view and you can
arrange them in some kind of space.
What kind of coherence, how much?
That's a good question.
Some kind of time,
some kind of cause of relation.
Well, now this inference,
you might sort of say, well,
now you might be inferring a world
specifically a structured world model
with spatial temporal
and causal properties
where things can unfold.
You can have something
like a stream of experience.
If this synchronization manifold
is basically giving you a joint belief
over your consortium.
And so it seems like alpha is a frequency
where you can get a big enough
of an agreement,
of a negotiated agreement
on a set up and a and a harmonic and on a
collective sense making
that you could bring together
all of the different body causes
head by egocentric preference
from terms of anatomy and like
what would be a sculpture and something.
So that's implicit
is there's this inverse relationship
there seems between the frequency
at which you can get
oscillations or harmonics and the scope
of what can be synchronized.
So you can get like a little thing
to agree really quickly,
but to get a big thing, it's
going to necessarily take more time.
And so more
things can come into the mix and
consciousness.
I'm wondering
if that is basically at a scope.
We're doing these joint
estimates of system world states
that let you both inform and be informed
by evolving action perception cycles.
But actually the functional codes
that you achieve for this estimation
process is out of proportion
of the events in the world
that are relevant to your affordances.
That actually would be part
of your policy selection,
and that if you can get this kind
of alignment of temporal dynamics
and if you're having these things
brought together in a way
that gives you
a point of view of some kind,
well, I might say OK, now it's
something like conscious thought,
this stream of experience
doing different things
where the thinking part of it
we might want to save that
or not for something like
imagine of planning or some sort of
like kind of like, like you're,
you're thinking of something
other than what is
and that's actually what's happening
at this intermediate level
where you are conscious, but you're
sussing out different possibilities
as you're trying to situate something
in some sort of coherent
spatial temporal
unfolding that you can make sense of.
And so the idea would be like everything
that we can think of,
we're necessarily temporal
izing and specializing
just so we can bracket like rocket.
I mean, literally
so we can bring it into some sort
of relation with this intermediate level
embodied simulation.
Otherwise we can't think of anything.
But I'd say there could be
a kind of unconscious thought.
Also, this actually might relate
to something like a counter
I think you can one counter in that this
this bundling
is that there's certain times at which
you can get a big enough of a coalition.
Like there's a time frame
for achieving that
in some ways
that's that's a kind of culture,
that's a kind of like discretization
and you might think of this
and something like that
and then act of inference
from just kind of discrete updating of
the generative model.
The but
it seems like you can get something like
unconscious thought potentially via
the hippocampal system
to kind of loop around the cloud
wearing a gun
in that one way, I would think of thought
as as generalized or navigation
through generalized space
hitting a particular
not arbitrary target,
being able to find your way there.
And so I've been working with
these are roboticists who are building
these slam systems in the simultaneous
localization and mapping.
And so what these robots are doing,
they're trying to figure out where am I
in this environment,
what is the sense of this environment?
And they're doing this actively
in terms of they're moving around
scouting out what's happening,
and there's this like mutually
constraining inference
of what is this world then
and where am I and what is this world
and where am I and figuring this out.
But this core system
that would seem to have within it
these these place fields,
these like locations that could be in
physical space, like the trees there
I'm here by my kitchen.
Zeller But it could also be
within a conceptual space.
And so there's sometimes model
this like bumper tractors
where like you get these
like local recurrences within this
like essentially located thing
and basically this chaining
of these bumper tractors
would then chain together broader
dynamics for the rest of the brain.
And so in theory, this could operate
in a way where you're not aware of it.
It's like coordinating sense making
and a kind of I sensory propositional
but in like an orderly way
there's like a topology to it.
And you went from here to here
to here to here.
So in theory
that could bypass consciousness.
I don't know if it can or not,
but this becomes like this
nested graphs of graphs, graphs.
There could also be
a kind of holography there potentially
in terms of
well, not whole RV,
not locality,
not holography, not locality there
in terms of when you
course screen
at some level.
Of course, creating a locality falls
where I'm not sure about that.
But yeah, so
those are some thoughts, some thought.
But one more thing, though.
So ultimately,
I think this is going to be
crucial are
understanding the principles
underlying this system,
not the system in a narrow sense,
but of this graphs of graphs, of graphs.
There's this where these interlude
processes have different capabilities.
It will be the secrets
to advanced intelligence.
And just like what do we want
from thought and cognition?
And I also suspect
it will be the answer to your question
and that what would make, I think life
clutter and more than a whirlpool
like you can so dissipate of systems,
they can be extremely impressive,
extremely lifelike,
but this sort of inter loop process
that can give you the sort of optionality
that this could potentially
a critically organized interview process
that can bind together overall dynamics
and get the overall system
because of this bifurcating
potential, this sort of optionality
that's going to be important.
Now, what if then this interlude system
is also a kind of counter
or a kind of like thing
that stitches itself together
where basically like genetic inheritance,
like it gives you
over it over time,
the ability to basically
get better priors into it, better
it lets you
as you transfer, learn and let's
see what happens here and influence
the next thing, influence the next thing.
And so this could be way
of what you could think of.
I'm Chewbacca. I think I'm ruining that.
I believe this unlimited associate
of learning
as like a hallmark of consciousness,
this kind of like transition
something like that, though this on
limited learning, open ended learning
as phylogeny,
as basically an internal process
capable
of coordinating the overall system,
which has some supply,
some sort of like pointer relation,
some sort of semantic pointers,
semantics, which itself is
allows for kind of heredity,
a kind of kind of inheritance
of whatever happened.
And so I think we bring
in those two things together and enter
the process
capable of some kind of counterfactual
processing and
link that to inheritance
now we'll have what we need
to have
either life or
a potentially conscious system.
Thank you, Adam.
I flip to the next slide on
diamonds and holograph.
Where does this come into play?
It's not something that you'd find
in the active inference literature today,
but maybe
it will be found there tomorrow. Why
calling on our diamond experts
yeah. Yeah.
Are we bypassing the diachronic
synchronic thing either? Yep.
We're wherever you want to go on this
life.
Yes. OK. Yeah. So
you know, so again,
if we're if, you know,
like Robert is saying,
ok, is the mind what the brain does?
Like, what is this?
What do we want from want
when you're when we're generating,
you know, in, like, pro
adversarial kind of,
you know, generative adversarial network,
you have this generator talking to
the like itself saying, no, no, no, no,
this is a cat.
This is not a cat.
And it's sort of
this is talking to itself.
What is that in us
when we're sort of talking to ourselves?
So again, you have someone like me
in the category theory side saying, OK,
I do think
there is some kind of strong duality
between the agent and the environment.
So if you if if minds are modeled
in this diamond way, right.
Then what you're actually doing
is just sort of engaging
with your reflections, right?
How do you actually engage
with your reflections,
your reflections of your reflection?
So kind of based on what Adam was saying,
it's like, what's the role of priors
and holograph what does it actually mean
to sort of have that?
That was my original question.
When an agent is figuring out how to jump
over a wall, it's never seen before
how is it doing that?
What if
affordances or just the set of parameters
that are built into the thing, right?
So let's try to do this then
if you could do this parameter free now,
what would that model actually
look like?
So for someone like me,
I am fascinated how when I speak to you,
the speech doesn't last, doesn't
last, doesn't last, doesn't last.
But somehow you remember what I say.
You remember what I say.
You must probably construct
a hologram holographic copy of of me
and what I'm saying
so that new store that somehow
so someone like me
with almost like a total
recall can remember stuff like this.
I know I can talk to people
and I have seven different versions
of time going on, you know,
how do you allied like all of
those seven you're just focusing on
like on what's happening now.
So you aren't really
so you have a crazy feedback processing
going on and none of this is happening
in real time, right?
Because there's neural
transmitters happening.
So this is already the past all of this,
whatever that means.
When we say the past
and so I'm just wondering with that,
when you have a very strict set of priors
governing how your agent behaves,
where do those come into play
and how do those work?
If the very way that the agent operates
is through holographic,
second holographic,
it's like you have a, you know,
some kind of dimensional relation
going on that perhaps now
we have a 2D retina for a 3D creature,
2D retinas, taking an information
and compressing it and then
reconstructing it in a higher way.
So that's just for that.
I have this model of,
you know, instead of just
having the normal holographic principle
which relates into the center
field theory, I'm trying to get it in
sort of a diamond way where you actually
use the analogy of diamonds,
which do these functions or computers
and build up a holographic
from an image Functor achieves.
So it's purely mathematical.
Let's just build up a holographic space
from image factors,
which is really relevant
to an act of inference.
You're acting,
you're acting, you're acting or acting.
There's no other definition than
a functor then some kind of relation.
So building up holography from relations
and the conformal aspect,
which is the metric free
sort of gravity free space, would be
in the finite condition of the diamonds.
So you have a six functor formalism
which is replacing anti the sitter space.
You have a finite condition
which is replacing the gravity three.
So that seems to me like a very
interesting way
to figure out how an agent is navigating
if you know there are reflections.
So the math part aside, just
what is the active inference experts?
Yeah. Think about
engaging with your reflections
that it's never really anything new.
You're just sort of walking around
in your echo space.
Thanks for the comment there, Adam.
And then anyone else for the recent.
So this might not doc, let's try
in terms of like the nature of like
how would I remember Shana or, and
how can I know anyone or anything
I'm wondering
if it always has to be through some kind
of generalized mirroring
with your own embodied experience.
And ultimately
it's got to be cash out that way.
And this the,
the particular nature of like the,
the hologram in terms of like the ability
to like reconstitute
and reducing the dimensions
and then expanding them again
would be by virtue of
you having this system which would just
get through a variety of reasons,
be able to
generate intelligent
coupling with the world of a sensory
motor variety,
but also run this same process
in an offline mode
so that you can imagine body simulation
and that if you then
so this the inactive inference, this
the sensory motor processes
are understood
as these self realizing predictions
where you'll set these equilibrium points
and then this hierarchy will just
sort of reconfigure and unfold.
And as it's jostling around and passing
this implicit prediction prediction
regard it just dynamically or just it'll
but by Hamilton's
principle, this action as as like
water flowing downhill, it'll find this
minimal state of minimal prediction error
that ultimately cache on reflex
arcs in the world
but for thought to be
the virtualization of that.
So you're imagining part of reaching out.
So you have this construct and system
in this virtual reality system.
And then if there's a reliable patterns
of coherent state transitions
that I'm likely to do
in different circumstances, well, now I'm
starting to get like an agent model
of myself, of the roots of a kind.
And you're showing it
if there's a reliable set of policies
that will happen
in different circumstances, like, OK,
well it's self-reflective,
then it seems you're going to
objectify the self somehow.
And I'm thinking
this likely comes through mirroring
actually through relationships
between parents and children at first
and that you're and where the parents
seem to be actually solicited in.
Some people say
the mirroring is the name.
I actually don't think it seems like
the parents help to solicit it,
but they mirror with you.
So that you learn to mirror.
And so that creates the learning
for them.
But through this,
these games play between
caretaker and child
you learn to get this mapping between
what's out there and what's here.
Somewhere along the way, you'll learn
to basically associate
what other people are doing in any way.
Even like you learn just to mirror
with them, they're over there.
And then you see that and you trust
analogy to your own embodiment, your own.
You put yourself in the same pose,
the same situation,
and then this now gives you a basis
for a kind of objectified self.
But it's still always
from like this egocentric perspective.
But now you're able to like
get this other person.
And I'm thinking that
that's like this kind of interface
for like my Shannon model
would have to be like the, the, the docking point would be something like this,
this third person
objectified selfhood,
which then would let you cash it out
or unpack it and embody cohere in a body
simulation, something like that.
So one thought about
like again set up and discriminators
it seems like that
that might be again crucial for
both hard problems and a challenge.
Your questions.
I think
there's this one
thinker is this academic psychiatrist.
Rucker did you plan on him having him on
Daniel or on you wrote this one paper.
He's fantastic, actually.
I think it'll be a good idea.
So but it's this idea of like so a system
basically
he calls it like allostatic overload
in a collapse model
where basically through these systems
that have these functional bottlenecks,
these bottlenecks will tend to kind of
that are
helping to establish the synchronization
manacle fill or a system
that the coordination that these heavily
trafficked and contingent areas
will tend to fail.
First, we stress the system too much.
And so
and this will give you like,
for instance, a kind of flexible
hierarchy
or other you're doing things maybe
unconsciously, but just like fast
feedback loops of the environment,
you're not getting fancy,
you know, cooking the dead
or you're letting yourself build models
upon models, reflection upon reflection,
but that these more rarified things,
they'll fail first.
And so you got this like you can move up
and down in sophistication
but I'm wondering whether in terms of
and so this
would apply not just to all intelligent,
all interesting intelligent
systems is the claim
but while you have this natural kind
of adjustment of your sophistication,
I'm wondering if it could be good
to have something
that preemptively anticipate this.
So you're not just having reactive
regime collapses here.
It's actually you can actually like,
you know, maybe not.
Yeah, I could switch to an unconscious
berserker mode right now.
Maybe
I don't want to be in that position.
And so if I can get something that's like
giving me a read on my degree of like
stress of allostatic load of degree
of like how, how close my to the edge,
that can be a good thing.
And so for the brain,
this would appear to be largely
the interior cingulate
would be probably the main
free energy or prediction area
integrator.
It's centrally located.
It has like in every sense
it's like boom,
got the most connectivity
and it's just perfectly suited
to say like how
well are you doing in self evidencing?
I'm wondering like within cells
if you have a similar kind of gan
like discriminator,
some sort of like inner metabolic cycle,
it like accumulates
and maybe like mitochondria
accumulating like radicals
or like some sort of like gene expression
loop,
I don't know, but something like this
that's highly central that like
when it starts to go,
this would then influence
your policy selection, this would
then influence your orchestration.
I don't know what
that would look like in a cell,
but for the brain this appears to be
there's does appear
to be some fairly centralized structures
literally that allow
for that kind of game like function.
And that is key to any
to basically intelligence agency
and is also key for things
potentially like
that.
I don't know if I believe this actually.
So Sam Gershman is argued
this is like reality monitoring
like a higher order thoughts sense
that I think something like that to work.
But the idea is that, you know,
how do I just think
if I just imagine something
or if I actually experienced it
and that there is some sort of
like gambling
discriminator to treat the whole
frontal lobes like this
and that that that's something else.
But it seems like this
though, can framework.
So this idea of discriminators
is extremely flexible, extremely powerful
and will apply across
a broad range of systems.
I think is actually really essential.
So yeah.
Thanks, Adam.
To bring it back to act
and for the diamond polygraph
I kind of drew two
diamond shapes on my page.
One was Person A and Person B
and their shared information on which
they're both looking at a whiteboard.
And so there's two people communicating
to the shared screen and unpacking.
And that was something we talked about
with Chris Fields.
And then to relate it to this diachronic
through time and synchronic
at the same time, I kind of thought about
like a bow tie or two diamonds where
in the current moment is the agents now
and then there's the agent in the future
and a inferred trajectory point
and then also in the past.
So we're sort of like retro acting.
We're now casting
and we're also predicting the future
and maybe the pathway through the past,
present future.
It's like a narrative that helps
the organism make sense of where it
is at that time.
But any other points on diamonds or
I think we can kind of go to the future
and give us
our closing thoughts and ask
you know, anyone who's watching
live can add a thought
or we can go around here as well.
What is the future of active inference
or a future or a direction
where do we see this fuels in the future,
ten years from now or some other time?
Point out,
will we be adapting active inference
to high level unsupervised learning?
Will we emerge
with strong artificial intelligence?
And where do we see embodied cognition
scaling to our ability to
blue?
And then Robert and then anyone else.
Robert, why don't you go ahead?
Yeah. Yeah.
Well, sure thinks so.
Just my personal opinion,
it would be very interesting to see.
And to what extent active in Friends
would or could move from.
I think now a lot of discussions
are kind of mechanistic.
I mean complicated mechanisms
which are happening
in the brain or in a cell or wherever.
I would be very interested whether that
with active inference could be a way of
precisely speaking about norms.
Normativity, I think someone mentioned
at the very beginning about it
said something about Normativity
what I mean with that
is that the distinction between
infer, inferring what is the case
or focusing on what is the case,
what physical stuff is going on,
and what should go on in philosophy.
This is famous distinction
that one could not be derived from.
Data goes back to David Hume
the author from is It's a Problem.
And I was wondering
whether active inference could be
could be an interesting middle way here.
And the second related thought is
which has to do with
AI and reinforcement learning.
We mentioned that in the very beginning.
The symptom seems to me to be good.
I mean, one could be very critical
and could say, well,
in some sense active inference,
that's very nice
and interesting
and one could do nice biology with it,
but it's not so obvious
what what the benefit
would be compared
to reinforcement paradigms.
And if one would be able to say
something reasonable
to this Normativity question,
then I think that's very
that would be a very big,
big plus point for friends.
But that's why I hope
that I kind of see in the future
book,
which goes more to the direction as well.
Thank you.
Robert Blue
so Robert,
just to kind of respond to that,
I don't know if you've seen the scaling
active inference paper that we looked at.
It's it's been a while but
yeah,
I remember who was the first author.
I forgot Alex. Chance.
Oh, Alex. Yes, of course.
So but he definitely compared active
in France
and a computational paradigm
to reinforcement learning.
So I don't know if you've seen that work
and you know,
in different testing different paradigms
the happened and the car
and the hills
and it was a nice picture anyway.
So where I would really like
to see active in inference in ten years,
I mean we talked about
how active inference is scale free
a scale free model
so theoretically
it should also be multi scale.
I think that there's a little bit
of a little bit of work to do
to get it to be multi scale.
So and I think that that work
definitely centers around emergence.
When does the next scale emerge?
When does a collection of cells
become a tissue
when does a collection of tissues.